with all the chaos in Gotham City
it isn't shocking that a few mistakes
have been made by the filmmakers who
brought the Dark Knight to the big
screen so what are some of the biggest
mistakes lurking in the Batman movies
caught red-handed when the Joker orders
his cronies to destroy everything in
Gotham's museum during Tim Burton's
Batman one henchman gleefully smacks a
bunch of red handprints all over a
painting but in the very next frame the
graffiti has magically disappeared and
he's back to defacing a painting from
earlier
mum's everywhere would probably like to
know where he got those washable paints
Joker's bloody chin moments before he
plummets from a helicopter the Joker is
visibly bloody from his mouth to his
chin and although the four kills him a
close-up shot reveals it somehow did
miracles for his beauty regimen Selena's
rearranging kitchen single lady Selina
Kyle is in such a rush when she runs out
of her apartment that she forgets to put
the milk back in the fridge but when she
returns after her little accident the
carton is nowhere to be seen and the
dishes in the drying rack are moved
around to did a cat's tidy up or did the
milk haven't even we're denied than she
did that's not the only weird thing
going on in her apartment
soon after the scene Selina starts to
assemble her Catwoman costume
brandishing a pair of blue scissors or
are they pink maybe it's Maybelline as
Batman prepares to reveal his identity
to Catwoman in Batman Returns he's seen
with his usual dark eye makeup
surrounding his eyes but after a quick
cut away it's suddenly gone this is
because he's about to remove his mask
and apparently it was about 25 years too
early for this look Ivy's vanishing
gloves
Batman and Robin from 1997 it had a lot
of
and simple continuity was one of them
seated in the backseat of the limousine
driven by Bane poison ivy is clearly
wearing black gloves when she begins to
put on a wig however in the next shot
her gloves are gone just another victim
of Joel Schumacher's madness
the spiked bracelets that wasn't the
only time Poison Ivy's arms with a
victim of bad continuity she's wearing
thin leaf-like gloves when she first
welcomes Robin into a lair but when she
angrily pushes him into a gross swimming
pool she's suddenly wearing spiky rubber
bracelets the transporting gun in Batman
Begins Bruce Wayne is waiting at the
courthouse to shoot Joe Chill the man
who killed his parents a female assassin
runs up and pushes a pistol up against
the criminals chest instead when she
shoots a split second later she's
holding the gun at least a foot away not
even Batman moves that fast where I oh
here
Joker's fast hands during the iconic
interrogation scene in the Dark Knight
the Joker and Batman tangled while the
Gotham City Police Department looks on
but it seems like they got a little more
tangled than anyone expected as Batman
holds Joker up against a wall
Joker holds on to Batman's arms with a
chin up grip but when the camera angle
changes the Clown Prince is doing a
pull-up instead before his hands quickly
return to their first position the
botched headline Gotham's copy editors
should probably get fired for this one
or at least the props Department in The
Dark Knight Rises Bruce Wayne stumbles
upon a newspaper headline while
conducting some online research about
the cat burglar in town where the word
heist is clearly misspelled I guess it
could have been worse thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which Batman movies
mistakes you've noticed